four-time BAFTA nominated composer
Murray gold is one of the UK's
best-known writers of television music
it's a genre that's so often demands
economy and instant originality and
those are qualities that gold is
displayed with great style over the last
decade or so early on in his career gold
seemed to glide with ease from one
landmark project to another dramas like
queer as folk Vanity Fair and shameless
featured offbeat quirky scores that
revealed Gold's preference for the
controversial and unusual but it was in
2005 when writer Russell T Davis
rebooted the classic BBC sci-fi series
Doctor Who for a new generation that
Murray Gold's huge popular appeal was
established writing a huge amount of
music for each episode with the full
might of the BBC National Orchestra of
Wales at his disposal Murray gold scores
for the series have become his signature
and the adventures of this timeless Time
Lord would simply not be the same
without him gold has become the soul at
the center of the series here at the
Royal Albert Hall Zell garu Murray gold
is talking to me about his career so far
and about the art of writing music for
television one of the things that I
always used to do is that I was always
interested in recording so I would take
a tape recorder and do that thing that
kids because sometimes work out that you
can do which is like you record yourself
playing the piano and then you play it
back and you take another recorder and
you record everything you play the the
playback of you playing the piano and
then you doing something else on top
with like bashing some spoons or
something so you've got percussion and
piano suddenly and and then I realized
there was a thing called a fortunate
recorder which actually does that
miraculously in one box so I I just
nagged and nagged and saved until I
could get one of those what's
interesting is that it's a actually a
very common story for for people who've
ended up writing for film and television
that they they really learn how to do it
in the theatre right because you're
having to learn to usually write for a
small number of visits yeah and the
function is very often very specific
yeah it is exactly like film in that you
have you have one plays worth of of
entries to make your point
and then you go home you don't it's not
like doctor we're nine episodes later
you suddenly realize you could have done
something really clever with that melody
it's like everyone left about fifteen
weeks ago by the way with theatre you
you you have to you know you you you've
got to get the smell of what the thing
is about go right to the heart of it
play a bit of music which lasts about
ten seconds before the before the
curtain goes up and it's got to tell you
everything about where the thing is set
what it's about what kind of tone it's
got whether it's a comedy or you know
and then you maybe have another bit of
in music in the interact you know and
then and then one at the end at the
interval so yeah you're right it's it's
a very precise thing to do when I sit at
the piano it's like that blank piece of
paper
it you know for any composer like in
George Orwell in 1984 when he get uni
looks at his blank creamy notebook and
you think wow anything is possible here
and a lot of it is sort of down to how
you play the piano and I like to
Theatre stuff got you know a documentary
director comes in and then it turned out
to be a guy called mark Munden in fact I
tried to play him some stuff I've gone
round to his house with the tape and
he'd really liked and he said it's kind
of got a style and its really
transparent he said I can't use you for
this but maybe I'll use it for the next
thing what happened which you can never
guarantee with anything you just this
one of those things where you know the
next thing I knew he said oh and the BBC
have just given me this Sunday night
drama called you know we're doing a
costume drama of Vanity Fair and I was
like great I'm so happy for you enjoy it
and then he said no no but I'd love you
Stuart
Lily there
when it was delivered I got this memo
because I don't think there were emails
in those days
it's like 98 I got this memo and it just
said is this a joke
there's so often a temptation for
composers to look for the exactly the
right kind of music for the right kind
of setting and the right kind of period
and you've sort of done the opposite but
it works perfectly because it gives it
such energy it goes right to the heart
of the of what the show is about it's
called Vanity Fair it's about the the
you know the decline of middle classes
and the elevation and then decline of a
woman who uses every every you know all
of her womanly tenacity to rise to the
top of society and collapse so is
theatrically it's it's about decay and
deprivation and you know the bourgeoisie
and sort of you know absence of values
so so it just felt like it should be
somewhat like you know Kurt Vile kind of
I my Republic kind of all these kind of
whatever I mean I try not to even ask
questions about that because you get so
literal about things you know it sounds
a cliche but if you feel like it works
just do it
Paul Abba had been watching it and
Russell was looking for the composer for
queer as folk and it was they were it
was exact same time I think probably
December 98 or something like that and
Paul Abbott and Nicola Schindler and I
you know worked a lot with both of them
and they're both geniuses of their field
they said who rat who's around who
doesn't write this is one of those
things who doesn't write TV music we
don't we just don't want TV music and
it's like I didn't have a clue what TV
music even was anyway I don't even know
what they mean by that I still don't
really but I think what you know they've
what they mean is they don't want stuff
that just feels in in the holes they
want tunes and melodies and things like
that and Paul Abbott said oh did you see
Vanity Fair and they said no and he said
well it's really you know what about
that so I'm in this hotel room with it
sharing my brother and suddenly this
phone rings he goes oh Murray you
and that score for Vanity Fair was
outrageousness of who is this is that
it's Russell Davis I've done this thing
it's called queer as folk I'm more proud
of it than anything I've ever done in my
life all of the shows I did you know not
Vanity Fair but subsequently from this
when northern working class drama and it
was you know it always fitted in with
the philosophy of life that I had that
you know life is just not a whole bed of
roses but when it's romantic and you're
you know deprived you know in
economically or emotionally or in any
form that that these stories like
clocking off and shameless and queer as
folk are set in you know a little bit of
love goes a long way and it means a lot
and so I would write these quite rote
romantic and offbeat scores to stuff and
I would make it triumphant and romantic
and happy where you wouldn't expect it
to be it just felt like oh what this is
actually about is the birth of sexuality
so needs to have sort of like that Eddie
Cochran rock and roll thing so that's
where all the strumming came from
if I'm working on a show I will do 40
versions of something myself and then I
will allow one out I just never put
three if you don't like this one here's
the other one
I just be like well this is it because
I've just sat through I've done 40 and
obviously you know sometimes people just
go god that's ghastly what on earth were
you thinking about
and then I resign do you I mean yeah
because they go back to the drawing
board and start again I'm terrible at
doing stuff again unless it's on for
something that I've seen because if
somebody tells me that they've seen
something and I haven't seen it I mean I
can try and see it but I've tried my
best to see what what is ins in the
material right at the beginning I mean I
haven't sat and done 40 versions of
something so that I can you know someone
can effectively tell me you're just not
seeing what this is about I mean it's a
little sit down and chat isn't going to
help that because that's just q1 so you
might as well bail but a lot of
composers say that it's much harder to
try and encapsulate the spirit of a
series in 30 or seconds or a minute than
it is to actually do a much more
expansive film-school that is true I
mean sometimes it does take to get to
the end before you know what the
beginning should be you know and I
actually had this thing when I was
working with Frank Oz he was like I did
Deathly a funeral and I arrived in New
York who's staying with my brother and
where he'd asked everyone to come to
work on the show and I had this back
room bedroom it was super hot and there
was no air conditioning and Frank Oz
came and said I'm presenting this show
at Tribeca grand tomorrow and I need
need the end cue it needs to be happy
and I said I haven't even seen the film
he said I don't care I need the n:q it
needs to be happy just go and do it I
mean what the hell do you do I mean you
just play a C major and play it didn't
and you know and there's fear that's
happy you want it happy that's happening
and was he happy no
well you mentioned Paul Abbott earlier
and we're moving on to shameless because
that's another one like queer as folk
that really became straight out of the
box immediately hit you with a style and
a confidence it was and the most
incredible show I've ever seen the first
two series and again when it arrived on
they arrived on video and it was shot as
if it's a home video I mean it just
looked terrible but there was just
something about when you got to the end
of the first episode which I think was
James McAvoy punching out a bouncer and
a couple of you know Manchester lasses
just laughing and looking at him
thinking like you're a hero and Frank
and everything about it it just made me
want to jump out the window in a good
way I mean this is music you like oh my
god this is like rock and roll this is
the most rock-and-roll television show
I've ever seen now nobody's saying that
Chatsworth his stay is the Garden of
Eden war it's been a good old source to
me Frank Gallagher and me kid powder
because every single one of them reminds
me a little of me they can't think for
themselves which it needs thankful when
I do a show when I do anything in life
at all you know I try and milk it for
all of the philosophical content I can
get from it because you're working with
people who were really brave passionate
about stuff who've got stuff to tell you
and you're basically privileged to be
spending time with them you know I grew
up in Portsmouth a middle-class family
and I'm hanging out with real you know
northern working-class writers you've
got amazing stories from themselves at
the like of which there is foreign to me
as they would be to someone from Mars
I was up in West Yorkshire Playhouse and
cuz I'd written this play and it was
being performed and Christopher
Eccleston Eccleston was starring in it
and and he kept on vanishing and not
learning his lines because he was doing
screen tests for this stupid thing and
obviously which nobody would watch and
why isn't he doing my play properly
and and then he came that he said to me
oh yeah this it's amazing it's amazing
Maury it's proper stuff what it's like
to mazing stuff like one of the
Companions goes and sees their father
died in its proper drama and I was like
yeah okay we could just do my play
please and and all of the Doctor Who lot
came up to see the play because they
supporting Chris and then there was the
announcement and then Chris sort of went
into a sort of he had played cat and
mouse with the press so I was right
there when all of that was happening but
was nothing at all to do with me because
that was some you know it was about
April or May 2004 but I just didn't
think about doing Doctor Who at all
really
and I got then I got an email and I
think I self subconsciously pretended
that I didn't want to do it and told
myself that as a kind of suck sucker for
for it you know not happening and and
then I got this email very close to the
time when it had to be finished like it
was October and the dub was in November
and it just said I'm doing this thing I
don't know how it'll work out but um I
should have asked you this months ago do
you want to do the music door too and I
was like I just wrote back yes that
would be great thanks and that
so then I had to go down to set and see
things happening and and and I made this
you know I made this tape and I studied
everything and I made this incredibly
electronic thing and then I went and
played it to Russell and Julie and I
think right at the end after about seven
and a half minutes of electronic stuff
there was this string cord and they've
goes well we like that and I was like
okay I think what you're telling me is
you want strings and they said yes and I
said well we don't have any budget for
any strings or anything like that and
you need the music
and that was dentist it would just
what's that that sounds good that's nice
I was there yeah okay well I'll do that
then and then I had to go and change my
computer because I used I don't know I
was using a computer program called
Cubase and I had to go and buy these
fake strings and I had to plug them in
using a software program I didn't know
how to use and then I in two weeks later
had to deliver the score and you know
and none of it's got any reverb on it or
anything like that because I didn't
realize that you should put reverb on
string samples otherwise because they
don't sound very realistic and and that
was broadcast
I have to ask you about the thing
because of course that is the thing that
everyone you was going to be in place it
had to be in place right so and you will
have known essentially the
responsibility of doing it so I didn't
you must have done you must have known
the theme anyway I knew the theme I mean
I was watch Doctor Who a lot I mean did
they say we need a new arrangement no
what happened was it came a bit later
where I think I'd done maybe one or two
episodes and because we had this big
amount of time December to April before
it was broadcast properly and I think
they were increasingly finding that as
they played it the theme just didn't cut
through and I mean it cuts through it's
sex sonically nothing cuts three more
you can't tame that thing it's a very
empty lonely sounding theme which is
fantastic and was fantastic it's just an
incredible piece of music and it it sort
of puts this fear you know into inside
you of being left alone in the dark and
with the visuals and everything
obviously its iconic but it was a very
different tone
you know the show was about love and
affection and it was warm I mean it was
warm occasionally in previous
incarnations of the show but this was
overflowing with war I mean it was the
warmest thing on television and why why
Doctor Who how did that happen
you know and so you know you get to the
end and it's incredible and this girl
has been effectively seduced to go off
in through space and time with the Tall
Dark Stranger and suddenly you just have
lonely and and scary and it just didn't
work so they said we don't want lonely
and scary so can you just you know do
something do something please I didn't
even know there were thirteen episodes I
just got through Episode one and then
they said there's you know and then
there's another one and then there's
another one and then there's another one
they I I don't think I ever asked anyone
single thing about what the show would
entail or what you know beyond that
initial meeting with Russell and Julie
the rest of the direction that the
advice I got was minimal but that
episode did have all of the themes in it
that all of the main themes were in the
episode that finished up in the 13th
episode so they all stayed through it I
just went about it in the exact same way
that I would any other drama as in treat
these characters sincerely treat them
like their hopes and expectations are
the your hopes and expectations don't
second-guess them be transparent if you
love them show you love them if you
don't love them show you know I mean it
no never never show you don't love a
guarantee
it's going to eat us
wait switch in the door it's fantastic
to have the orchestra I mean the the
number of notes that I write and the Ben
orchestrates well we I was gonna mention
Ben Foster because he he's just sort of
right-hand man on this project isn't he
is yeah Ben orchestrates from my MIDI
files basically a MIDI file is I will
give a piece of music that sounds like
that to Ben and he will notate it for
the instruments of the orchestra my
versions come in varying degrees like
sometimes if we really push because like
I did I had to write the music for not
not the Christmas carol but actually the
the one that followed that that doctor
Widow in the wardrobe because of various
things to do with the schedule had to
write that in 10 days so and that was
about an hour's worth of music and for
Orchestra so I would just just sit down
and write first thing in the morning and
just keep trying I mean trying to get
through 10 minutes a day which actually
for me is is not unusual but it's still
spiritually draining one of the unusual
things about the Christmas Carol episode
is that music is also part of the
narrative in a sense I've got Katherine
Jenkins as a guest star in the program
and she sings in it but she sings in it
for a reason right it's written into the
script yeah there's a song to be sung in
it I hadn't read the script actually it
had been sitting in my inbox where I
don't have an inbox but you know her me
and Beth previous except producer had
said you've every read the script Mary
and I said yeah jazz great
fantastic what a script and she said so
have you done the song and I said
there's a song and she said yes you you
know that bit towards the end where
somebody sings and saves the entire
universe and because they've been let
out of their prison for one day which
the person who's been in love with them
for all their life and it turned him
into a really miserable bastard has been
and he releases her for one day and she
sings to him and it's going to be one of
those kind of iconic moments on British
television I was like oh that's no
pressure whatsoever and she and then she
said well Katherine Jenkins is flying in
from Russia on Friday and I was like
which Friday you know it as in now is
Wednesday tomorrow is Thursday and the
next day is Friday and I was like
fantastic
I love my own
by this point the Christmas specials in
particular are getting 11 12 million
people watching them on Christmas Day a
family experienced one of the few I
guess on television that we get these
days do you ever even remotely think
about that while you're doing it do you
feel that pressure no not at all
no I mean I just I mean I mean I think I
probably feel I'm like the old guard on
Doctor Who now you know I'm the one
that's been there all the time and I
feel like if I respond to something a
certain way I think every to some extent
people use me as an emotional gauge for
you know what it's about I mean it
hasn't even been known that somebody has
asked do I like it as if it mattered
from within the you know from you know
what does Mary think about it because
normally that question is only put to
well what did you know the people with
the power think about it yeah I don't
have the power I just occasionally
someone listens to me when you associate
a theme with a character you love of
course it's going to get the emotional
drive that the you know the whose theme
is always going to be Doctor Who that's
what it is but you know when I am the
doctor represents Matt Smith and he will
it will always represent Matt Smith for
people now that's just done
you have to be able to support yourself
somehow you have to have a roof over
your head but you have to try and meet
people who will either putting on plays
or making stuff for the internet
whatever it is you have to do stuff all
the time you have to churn out music
because it's all very well spending five
years you know waiting and writing your
masterpiece but you've got to be able to
write music very fast every single day
because when that time comes you're not
going to get any run-up for it you've
got to hit the ground running
so hopefully that time will come but you
have to just use every means possible
you have to be a street fighter about it
because if you're not in the privileged
section of daughter son of somebody
famous if you don't you know if you're
not born and bred in LA if you all of
these things make it more difficult for
people to attract attention but never
attract attention by waving stuff in
people's face so that you really tick
them off you know you wanted you want a
bit of pull towards you you want people
to see your stuff and you just want
people to feel that there's and don't
try and do what everybody else does I
just got so tired of hearing people
doing imitations of hands Zimmer you
know because they're 21 22 years old and
you're like why are you trying to do
hands in my hands immer already does
handsome what you want to do is come to
the thing from a different angle and
just express yourself constantly and if
you and I mean I know this sounds
idealistic but if you are doing it
because you love doing it then you'll
never gain there's no bad side to that
is there it's no bad side you just you
know I sometimes made this joke like
don't tell anyone that I would do this
even if I wasn't paid to because then
they won't pay me the things that I
choose to do I have to have a way into
them I have to love them because
otherwise I don't know how I'm going to
work on them I just allow myself to make
myself upset while I'm watching this
thing and sometimes it's ridiculous and
it seems really narcissistic if in one
way but I will sit there imagining
something
we'll bawl my eyes out you know and in
the end it's like it's really good to be
able to trust that mechanism because
that is ultimately anywheres probably
tons of you here that can write music
and that's not really you know music is
an hour and and this is more of a sort
of craft thing and sort of just you can
you can make somebody cry with one
little piano chord it's just about where
you're putting that stuff and as as
Richard Ellis the film critic wrote
writing film music is not writing film
scores you know it's where it goes and
so I really trust my inner mechanism
it's yet that one of the only things
about myself I do trust is my own inner
mechanism for for working out what is
going on in a scene and what people will
respond to
you